what are you doing here I'm flying back
to New York with you Rachel true will
you marry me
yeah I've been like for an on-time
departure can this wait hey I'm Sarah
and I'm Heather and we're flight
attendants and we're gonna review
airplane scenes from TV and film miss no
it's not me
yes it is you please go back to your
seat bridesmaid I love this this is kind
of an iconic scene in modern day flight
attendant movies what did you give away
I tell people to drink one glass of wine
to relax if they're nervous I don't go
overboard this is a passenger disturbing
it was threat level one right level one
is disruptive behavior and then threat
level two is physical so that could be a
passenger getting this another passenger
or they get getting physical at you you
touch the shoulder do not touch your
flight attendant it's so important we're
level three is life-threatening
it goes up to level four where it's
breech of the cockpit so you have you
know which one is which level so when
you call up the captain you tell them
what level it is when we have a drunk
passenger they're usually not that much
fun do you guys have any tampons it
could go sorry no we don't but we have
soft drinks and food for an additional
charge so the broad broad city there are
actually tampons on the bathroom fYI
there's also big old maxi pads over
there look at this snack box it's like
that's - eminence and one olive it's a
no crash it's using that always bothers
me so much no eat before you get on a
plane because a lot of people will come
up to me and be like I'm starving and
I'm like oh I have our pretzels today or
whatever depends on what catering is
given me so how's the drink
it's good that wasn't a very strong
reaction well it's not a very strong
drink we're gonna watch the lost yeah
I've seen that view before the very
first before she gave it to him double
is the maximum out you can't give
somebody a triple in one serving it's
gonna hit you faster than you think yeah
you get to wait quicker in the air than
you do on the ground
my husband keeps reminding me that
planes want to be in the air he sounds
like a very smart man oh this is why
they always say over and over to put
your seatbelt on turbulence is just like
grinding a horse bag on down dirt road
you're gonna be alright
yes I mean maybe not in this show oh
yeah
okay where'd they come from the overhead
bins and that got it up remember over
your nose and mouth and strap yours on
before you help anyone else oh good oh
my gosh I hope they're not doing
beverage service at this time still you
know how they say don't watch scary
movies alone well it's kind of like
don't watch a scary airplane movie
before you get on a flight wait all the
time
airplane oh this is iconic the best
movie don't show I usually give them
some hot tea with lemon that usually
helps how many people they're just out
of theirs be ready okay
yeah get that weapon on board yeah this
is before they had TSA hmm
makes on a plane its are definitely not
service animals you can't bring them on
the plane no matter what you try you're
not allowed to bring down the plane the
one place that you feel is safe how did
all these snakes get on the plane would
you try to protect yourself the to help
anyone I don't even know what you could
do it's number one you ladies and
gentlemen if you are a snake charmer
could you please Road bring your call
time thank you
yeah I hope I don't have to deal with
half these scenarios ever when it comes
to snakes every man for himself
[Music]